before covet hit we were all
totally fried stressed burned out
we were already out of gas and we were
able to um
you know compress our sadness we were
able to hide our frustration and
exhaustion through busy and busy and
busy
and buying things and running and
scrolling through things
we were able to just kind of shove it
aside we were able to
um wallpaper over the cracks and our
marriages
and in our friendships with busyness and
kids soccer games and another dance
recital another thing another thing
and then covet hit and we all had to go
home and we all had to stare at each
other
and stare at each other and then some of
us across the country
are still having to just stare at each
other but before
covet we were seeing a massive increase
across the country
in what researchers are calling diseases
of despair
and diseases of despair are suicide
organ disease failures like um liver
disease
heart disease those are diet related
those are
often depression related um and an
increase in addiction
and so the average lifespan in the u.s
had actually gone down the last few
years before
covet hit and these were all diseases of
compression
diseases of despair to nerd out a little
bit if you take a normal bell curve
some have even taken to calling this
long tail suicide
which means people aren't acutely
killing themselves
they're not using a gun or pills or
something like that jumping off a bridge
but they are coming home from work
they are overweight they are grabbing
poison out of their pantry or poison out
of their fridge or they're driving
through and grabbing some poison
they are sitting on the couch and
drinking and numbing
and eating and lonelying themselves to
death
it's a cultural country-wide crisis
and it's not even cult it's not even our
country it is turning into a global
thing
we are just so spun out and so exhausted
and good folks this was before covet
right
and so i was checking out the data
recently on
the covet related mental health issues
and there is just expert after expert
after expert predicting
what they're calling a far worse mental
health pandemic that's going to last for
years and years beyond covid
major increases in hotline calls
major increases in telehealth referrals
and
calls during covid some of that is great
i'm glad people are using these
resources but it's
it's again anxiety alarms they let us
know when we're disconnected
when we are in situations where we don't
have control or
our lack of predictability and
or when we are scared when we are
fearful and that's what covet has done
to us man
so here's what i want people to be weary
of i want them to
get on their guard a little bit i wanted
to exhale
start making plans again because here
we're coming into winter
and the we we have
had outside adventures we could just go
for walks we've had sunshine we've had
outside events we've started figuring
out ways to do outside kid things right
we were able to walk our dogs and all
that we're getting into winter
when it is cold and it is dark and our
tendency naturally is just to stay
inside
and we're gonna have to be so
intentional
so intentional about living lives that
don't
compound this already growing anxiety
this already
growing depression that's already
growing inner
this inner dysthymia oh and by the way
we have an election coming
luckily it's not a contentious election
and everyone's on the same page so
that's cool
good good grief so i want to read you a
couple things
a cd receive report revealed that as of
late june
about 25 of adults in the u.s had
reported symptoms
of an anxiety disorder that is triple
the rate of 2019 and my guess is that
many people are experiencing this
beyond that they just don't have the
words for it they don't have time
because they're too busy working
that third job trying to make ends meet
one in four young adults age 18 to 24
has seriously considered suicide in the
past month that absolutely breaks my
heart i've been to too many funerals
i've been to too many ugly situations
in dark homes and i've hugged too many
moms and dads
one of the unspoken burdens is on unpaid
caregivers and workers who are
taking care of adult kids with special
needs who are taking care of
aging parents who are taking care of of
aging spouses
who are taking care of little kids folks
who aren't getting paid for this this is
just there every single day
and six months seven months of this
with no end in sight it just begins to
take a toll on your soul
right and so here's the thing
um we're gonna have to be highly
intentional here's five things
five's a lot but five things that you
can do
start right now as we are heading into
october
um as we are in early october start
now getting routines getting plans
together getting people together in your
life so you can get on top of this
before it just wipes us out come
february
so number one no matter what get
outside make it a regular practice to
get outside if it's cold
bundle up if you are freezing
figure out a way to do it buy warm
clothes get yourself a toboggan get used
to the cold your body will
adjust find places to hike by the way
hiking is just fitness nerds speak for
going for a walk hike walk
play go outside during your work day
people have been going outside to smoke
for years just go outside and take a
15-minute lap around your building it's
healthier for you than smoking
but make sure you get outside outside
number two
however you can wherever you can be with
people in person buy a heater better yet
buy some blankets
they aren't for decoration on your couch
anymore they're actually for keeping you
warm
if you have to be outside with people be
outside get underneath them and
figure out how you can be in community
with other people
i don't care if you don't like them i
don't care if you think they're weird
spending time with other people is
critical over the next five to six
months
if you are isolated or alone and you
can't get outside you came with other
people
face time regularly make it a point to
call somebody every single day
in march of last year when this kicked
off i was real good about it and i've
actually fallen off
and so it's become one of my regular
practices to get on the phone and call
people every single day i've even taken
the leaving hilarious messages on their
phone
i just call them and act like an idiot
on the phone it's important
number three do online counseling if you
need to if you need a professional
everyone's throwing their practice up
online go
find somebody number four get an eating
plan and an exercise plan even if it's
in your living room
my wife and i moved our gym into our
living room for a season before we moved
to our new place
that's got a garage because no one was
coming over and we both know the
connections between mental health and
physical health so we just moved our
furniture out of the way and we put our
weights and stuff in the living room
and it worked out great for us it wasn't
pretty it wasn't nice it made the house
smell a little bit i don't care it was
important
eating plan eating plan eat real food as
much as possible
if you're interested on how i eat and
what my thoughts are nutrition and
mental health
i can do a whole segment on this stuff
i've been researching this stuff for
years
if you're on your own get it but take
care of your eating plan
and then the number five is start
creating
start creating there's something about
the creative process
that is therapeutic and heals us from
the inside out that can be riding
building
gardening go hunting and fishing dig a
hole
move rocks one of the things we've done
for our young son who's got a lot of
energy
in a small house is we give him one hard
job a day
he gets one hard job a day it could be
weeds
it could be moving rocks around it could
be mowing it could be whatever the thing
is
it could be moving books around the
living room but i've seen his shoulders
stand up a little bit taller he's
finding some esteem that he may have
been missing he is
solving problems and it is helping all
of us around the house so
um find ways that you can create find
ways that you can move so
again i'm very concerned about this
oncoming
winter shutdown which is just a natural
depressing of everybody's mood that
happens every winter it's just part of
the season
it's going to be especially hard this
year so let's start planning
now let's start planning now to get
ahead of this